>> Tucker: THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY UPHELD        APPEARED ON C
WRAY UPHELD        APPEARED ON P
WRAY UPHELD        APPEARED ON T
WRAY UPHELD        APPEARED ON L
WRAY UPHELD        APPEARED ON H
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF HIDING
INFORMATION FROM CONGRESS.
HERE'S PART OF THE EXCHANGE.
>> IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT
THIS PRESIDENT ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY, PRESENTED TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING THAT
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
I THINK RIGHT NOW ALL OF US ARE
BEING DENIED.
WHATEVER YOU'VE GOT, FINISH IT
TORN APART.
>> WITH REGARD TO THE
INVESTIGATION, I HAVE HEARD
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE SHOULD JUST
CLOSE THE INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THE BEST THING WE CAN DO
IS FINISH IT APPROPRIATELY AND
REACH A CONCLUSION.
>> Tucker: TOM FITTON IS THE
PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL WATCH AND
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
TOM, WHEN IS THIS GOING TO WRAP
UP, DO WE HAVE ANY SENSE OF AN
>> THERE IS NO IMMINENT END
DATE.
THIS OBSTRUCTION INVESTIGATION
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE RUSSIAN
COLLISION INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THERE HAS BEEN NO RUSH
IN COLLUSION WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT MUELLER IS DOING.
HE HASN'T PRESENTED ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE HE IS IN
HIS INVESTIGATION.
RANKLY, HE SHOULD BE ON THE HILL
TESTIFYING SINCE HE SEEMS TO BE
THE ONE RUNNING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER.
>> Tucker: SO HOW DID THEY
RESPOND, UNDER THESE QUESTIONS?
>> THEY SEEM, I THINK, OBLIVIOUS
TO THE CONCERNS AMERICANS HAVE
ABOUT THE CREDIBILITY AND
LEADERSHIP OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI.
OBVIOUSLY UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IT WAS AN
ABSOLUTE DISASTER.
DOESN'T TRUST THEM TO TURN OVER
THE DOCUMENTS I HAVE AND IT
CERTAINLY, THE DIRECTOR DOESN'T
SEEM TO THINK THE IG REPORT WAS
ABOUT THE FBI.
HE KEEPS THINKING THAT IT WASN'T
ABOUT THE INSTITUTION OF THE FBI
WAS A LEADERSHIP OF THE FBI THAT
MR. ROSENSTEIN HAS PRODUCED BY
WITH SUBPOENAS IN A TIMELY WAY
AND HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY EXCUSES
AS TO WHY IT TAKES YEARS AND
MONTHS TO TURN OVER A BASIC TEXT
PRESSED ON, HE SAID I HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WORKING ON IT VERY
HARD AND IF THEY MISS IT OR
THERE ARE MISTAKES THAT ARE MADE
I WOULD GO BACK AND SHARE THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THEM.
IT DOESN'T SOUND VERY SATISFYING
TO ANYONE WHO IS TRYING TO GET
A GENERATION.